siempre en movimiento
mi padre
un hombre hijo de inmigrantes libaneses
que llegaron a colombia en la primera
guerra mundial
un hombre con una mente prodigiosa una
inteligencia especial realmente por
encima del promedio un gran emprendedor
un gran empresario y sobre todo un
hombre muy valiente
alrededor de 1989
él conoce
un técnico de alimentos que se llamaba
mario mario es un italiano que llega a
colombia en los cincuentas traído por
una empresa de alimentos muy importante
y luego de trabajar muchos años decide
jubilarse y daba asesoría a unas pocas
empresas más bien pequeñas en esa época
mi padre lo conoce y le propone que
diseñe una fábrica de dulces
la idea de mi padre era aprovechar el
azúcar del valle del cauca un azúcar de
precios muy competitivos una ubicación
geográfica especial cerca al puerto para
montar una empresa con vocación
exportadora
algo que era importante que era que
había muy poca plata habían muy pocos
recursos y le dijo a mario que tenía que
hacer algo supremamente austero en ese
momento yo me encontraba en la
universidad
con muy poco dinero
se logró instalar una línea de chupetes
en 1991 la maquinaria fue ordenada a un
taller en el centro de cali que se
llamaba tangarife era un taller
rudimentario picapiedra no tenían
tecnología por supuesto pues no se podía
esperar mucho del producto cada chupete
que se fabricaba era diferente de pesos
diferentes de formas diferentes unos
aplastados unos ovalados realmente muy
difícil tampoco había plata para
envolver los chupetes y en esa época
contratamos a 60 madres de familias
sentadas en una mesa con una resistencia
para que volvieran los chupetes
manualmente uno a uno recuerdo que cada
mujer cada señora envolvía 4000 chupetes
en un turno de ocho horas realmente fue
muy difícil aún así logramos producir
chupetes
en junio de 1991 sentado en mi oficina
me llama don mario' me dice leonardo
baja la planta que vamos a sacar la
primera producción feliz bajo iniciamos
y empezamos a ver salir los chupetes a
los 20 minutos
'don mario' me dice me duele el pecho
creo que tengo un infarto
yo tenía veintiún años de ciencia de la
universidad como 'don mario' los montos
en miches destartalado y nos vamos a
toda velocidad a la clínica de occidente
lo entregamos al médico lo revisa y
afortunadamente era un preinfarto
a las 3 horas me llama mario y me dice
leonardo
regreso a mi jubilación
no puedo trabajar más mi salud no lo
permite momento bastante difícil porque
no había mucho conocimiento sobre el
tema
aún así tocaba que iniciar buscar
clientes buscar mercados el primer
cliente fue un haitiano que se llamaba
reno dura viene a nosotros nos contactan
venid a colombia compraba productos de
diferentes fábricas productos de consumo
masivo los montaba a su propio bar con
barquitos muy pequeños sobre borda los
transportaba desde cartagena haití
puerto príncipe y los vendía en los
mercados mayoristas y recibimos nuestro
primer pedido 30 toneladas de confites
en ese momento es barato para nosotros
nos reunimos con el equipo y empezamos a
fabricar las 30 toneladas pasado 23
semanas lo llamamos tenemos el producto
listo lo recoge nuestra planta lo
transporta cartagena y a los 15 días nos
llama y nos dice hombre hubo una
tormenta y todo el producto se nos cayó
al mar está en las profundidades del mar
caribe
difícil comienzo meses después nos llama
el presidente de la compañía más grande
de alimentos de colombia
y nos dice que está interesado en una
primera producción de 30 millones de
chupetes con la marca de ellos un
presidente de la compañía más grande de
colombia realmente era impresionante
fuimos a visitarlos cerramos el negocio
reúno a todo el equipo y le digo ya
tienen que hacer esto bien no podemos
fallar esta es una oportunidad única era
la producción de tres meses
e iniciamos la producción día por día
con todos los cuidados todos los
controles y a los tres meses llamó al
señor rafael don rafael sus 30 millones
de chupetes están listos como debía ser
enviaron un equipo de inspectores
revisar que el producto cumpliera las
especificaciones vienen a cali y a las
pocas horas de realizar ensayos nos
dicen el ciento por ciento del producto
está rechazado
al que se le caía el palito a los
chupetes y eso pero realmente no era la
idea
difícil realmente fueron momentos
bastante difícil
aún así
seguimos avanzamos en ese momento
nuestro producto era barato era
económico realmente la visión de mi
padre de tener a la mano
y una azul un azúcar realmente de buena
calidad de precios competitivos nos
permitía ofrecer un producto económico
hicimos algunas mejoras y nos fuimos a
visitar todos los países de
centroamérica caribe hicimos algunas
mejoras para lograr por lo menos un
producto aceptable la máquina
troqueladora la cambiamos por una
máquina china que era bastante mejor y
logramos algo que para esos mercados
donde la calidad no era lo más
importante era suficiente logramos
entrar en panamá costa rica república
republicana
haití jamaica me perdona puerto rico
en ecuador venezuela y en cada país
logramos ventas pequeñitas algún
mayorista por aquí otro mayorista por
acá eso nos permitió crecer nos permitió
mejorar la calidad comprar máquinas un
poco mejor ampliar nuestras capacidades
procesos mejorados y eso fue un período
importante para nosotros de allí pasamos
a las ferias empezamos a asistir a
ferias en eeuu yo iba con mi esposa a
hoteles económicos tres estrellas y nos
cogíamos alquilamos un stand pequeño con
unas mesas muy pequeñas sobre las mesas
exhibíamos el producto recibíamos
clientes y pudimos abrir nuevos mercados
eso fue algo bastante importante
entender que en esas ferias los
contactos nuevas sidras del caribe
nuevos países de centroamérica en eeuu
empezamos a abrir mercados también de
productos económicos más también en
chile perú bolivia
y también crecer un poco en colombia fue
un período de expansión importante y
dimos un salto
de manera significativa
aprendimos que este negocio
si queríamos sobrevivir no era de
productos baratos era de crear marcas de
crear conceptos diseño gráfico en que
hay un publicista que debe entender
bastante sobre el tema había que mejorar
no podíamos seguir simplemente productos
con en posturas que eran transparentes
que eran commodities sino que teníamos
que crear unas marcas poderosas en 1000
y 998 nos unimos a la agencia de
publicidad young & rubicam en ese
momento pues tampoco teníamos dinero
para pagar unos honorarios altos pero
logramos una negociación razonable con
la gerente de la oficina de cali y le
decimos necesitamos una marca ellos
todos sus equipos creativos y a los seis
meses
nace la marca juguetón nos reunimos con
todo el equipo ya teníamos un gerente de
mercadeo y decidimos jugárnosla todas
con un lanzamiento con bombos y
platillos en nuestro primer lanzamiento
realmente de una marca que esperábamos
que fuera de dos contratamos un
comercial que se filmó en chile-
comercial que fue una inversión muy
importante para nosotros en ese en ese
momento realmente hicimos tres
comerciales cada uno de 10 segundos
diseñamos el producto los sabores los
empaques
y me fui en el año 2000 a negociar los
medios con el vicepresidente comercial
de caracol me fui y le conté la historia
le mostré los estudios de mercadeo el
producto producto gustaban sabores
diferenciados y después de regatear y
regatear y regatear lo logré en negociar
un mes de pauta
y realmente todo el presupuesto que
tenía lo tenía invertido en ese mes de
pauta el regreso a cali me reúno con el
equipo y les digo logramos una tarifa
muy especial realmente no podíamos pagar
sino unos precios realmente bajos en la
televisión pero él nos ayudó
y decimos vamos a hacer un lote vamos a
llenar las bodegas de juguetes porque
esto va a ser un hit vamos a reventar
las bodegas iniciamos producción en
junio del 2001
jugué tarjetas y empezamos y sale el
comercial comercial sale en julio
pauta pauta en prime las mejores spots
los mejores programas
todos los días nos llegan las órdenes
nos llegan las órdenes pasó una semana
ni una orden
dos semanas se colocaba algunas cajitas
pero no rotaban o sea que pasa puede ser
tres semanas ya se estaban acabando la
pauta cuatro semanas se acaba la pauta
teníamos 30.000 cajas se han vendido 500
yo dije esto no puede ser sea
supuestamente la pauta el consumidor
genera la demanda y el producto de
venderse y no teníamos plástico me voy
para donde el vicepresidente otra vez y
le cuento la historia y le digo
yo estoy convencido de que esto es
cuestión de tiempo los estudios nos
muestran de que el producto es exitoso
tiene que venderse pero necesitamos más
tiempo me tocaba que decirle que no
tenía un peso
entonces horas explicándole le hice una
propuesta
le doy un porcentaje de las ventas
y si las ventas son realmente buenas le
sube el porcentaje y usted gana y alto
órgano
pero inicialmente me dice que no que esa
clase de negocios son muy difíciles
finalmente aceptó llegó otra vez regreso
a cali con el equipo
emocionado digo vamos para adelante esto
nos va a funcionar al segundo mes las
ventas se disparan
tres meses logramos una participación
del 15 por ciento del mercado luego de
tener el 2 por ciento eso fue un primer
éxito importante esto marca un nuevo
hito en la compañía una nueva etapa
y decidimos construir una nueva fábrica
una fábrica con la mejor tecnología una
fábrica de 28 mil metros cuadrados una
capacidad importante con gas a todas las
digamos las técnicas buenas prácticas de
manufactura
y aparte algo importante es que
empezamos a participar en las ferias de
europa las ferias son las más
importantes y son ferias para mercados
diferentes en las ferias de europa van
los africanos los asiáticos los países
árabes y empezamos a vender en todos
esos esos países de aquí un contenedor
otro contenedor y en una de esas ferias
llega un cliente de sudáfrica
empezamos le tomamos una orden y a los
meses le comentó del éxito que tuvo yo
que está
en colombia y luego de colombia me faltó
decir habíamos llevado ese éxito a
ecuador-venezuela países de
centroamérica y en cada país realmente
los resultados eran bastante positivos
entonces le digo porque no lo traduce al
inglés y lo pauta había un inconveniente
pues las personas los actores del
comercial eran chilenos y algo diferente
a los surafricanos
pero de todas maneras le dije juguemos
hoy en día pues blanco negro café somos
lo mismo juguemos a ver qué pasa
julio del 2003 de algunos despachos y a
los meses decide pautar el mismo
comercial en inglés a los tres meses me
dice cuál es su capacidad le compro toda
la capacidad
yo le digo no pues yo tengo otros
clientes pero empezamos y rápidamente
áfrica se vuelve en el primer mercado de
la empresa no solamente sudáfrica sino
que posteriormente así como desde
colombia exportamos el comercial a
ecuador-venezuela países de
centroamérica en áfrica lo hicimos a
zambia mozambique congo angola y
realmente se volvió nuestro segundo
hogar yo empecé a visitar 34 veces al
año el continente porque no era un país
yo recorría todos los continentes desde
angola el congo desde zambia tanzania
mozambique sudáfrica su gráfica siendo
el más importante aquí hay unas fotos
con mi después en un colegio con mis
hijas
no hay una idea de lo que es el áfrica y
en todos esos países yo que está se
volvió la marca número uno en todos esos
y se convirtió en el 50 por ciento de
todas las ventas
nos ganamos premios reconocimientos este
es un premio que lo genera la
publicación sunday time después de 5.000
encuestas y logramos lo que se demanda
culés brands del mercado en toda la
canasta de confitería esto es de
sudáfrica llevamos 10 años estando en
los primeros 10 de los 10 años como tres
o cuatro primer puestos y es algo que
bastante importante
el modelo de exportación ese modelo que
pensó mi padre cambió el mundo cambió
desde el 2002 viene la famosa
revaluación
el dólar en el 2002 llegó sin mal no
recuerdo a 2.800 y al final de la década
de 1800 quiere decir que por cada dólar
aldo recibía un 40% menos de ingresos
eso es una catástrofe cuando el 80% de
toda nuestra producción era de
exportación o sea que entre más
vendíamos más perdíamos dinero
a todo ese éxito de estos sueños estaban
realmente en riesgo y estamos bastante
endeudados porque habíamos terminado de
construir una planta enorme en el 2004
en la que ustedes vieron osea que los
créditos estaban bastante complejos
teníamos que repensar todo el negocio no
era sostenible perdíamos dinero le digo
a la familia tenemos que crecer en los
mercados locales el mercado de sudáfrica
no lo podemos abastecer desde la planta
de colombia simplemente nos cambio las
condiciones y el negocio realmente
estaba en riesgo
en el 2010 le presentó un proyecto a la
familia
encontré una fábrica que estaba quebrada
en johannesburgo y la idea era alquilar
la para trasladar nuestras máquinas que
estaban en la planta de cali a sudáfrica
y poder producir localmente este fue un
proyecto
en seis meses logramos iniciar
producción
logramos alquilar adecuar empaquetar la
maquinaria despacharla por mar y en
enero del 2011
iniciamos producción de una planta
en johannesburgo suráfrica esto fue algo
supremamente importante era la única
manera de poder mantener nuestro
liderazgo en sudáfrica que para ese
entonces ya habían cuatro fábricas de
confites de chupetes
también se le propuso a la familia que
teníamos que crecer colombia
y en el 2009-2010 compramos una y
hacemos una fábrica de gomas en ese
momento las gomas era el producto de
mayor crecimiento y en el 2011 en una
reunión muy casual con la presidenta del
grupo nutresa aparece la oportunidad de
comprar la marca from a es una marca
tradicional y esa era nuestra
oportunidad para fortalecernos en el
mercado colombiano que a diferencia del
mercado africano no teníamos marca
líderes vendíamos teníamos segundas
terceras cuartas marcas pero realmente
no teníamos marcas líderes y en ese año
en un proceso de competencia abierta se
logra cerrar el negocio de frutas
que somos hoy hoy entre las dos plantas
fabricamos más de 50.000 toneladas al
año de confites no solamente chupetes
hoy hacemos caramelos blandos las gomas
la planta de gomas que inició en el 2011
ha ido creciendo toffees mentas
más de 2 billones dos mil millones de
chupetes al año son como 2.4 2.400
millones de chupetes al año entre las
dos plantas
exportamos seguimos exportando ya las
entre colombia y sudáfrica es el 70 por
ciento de la producción y así pudimos
cambiar el modelo exportación a
producción local pero seguimos
exportando a 40 países y ahora con la
recuperación de del cambio pues somos
competitivos de nuevo
y nuestras marcas clic trolley play
juguete toffees son nuestras marcas
principales
el mensaje pues todo comenzó con un gran
sueño
esa idea y ese sueño fue mi padre
hubieron muchas adversidades muchas
algunas veces
no veíamos el mañana y se me olvidó
decirles una anécdota que cuando esta
empresa rechaza los 30 millones de
chupetes tenían justificación para eso
mi padre le dijo al presidente sabe qué
llévese la fábrica que si usted con la
fábrica
y afortunadamente la persona dijo no
está fábrica no no me sirve no tenía las
condiciones afortunadamente dijo que no
pero con mucha perseverancia con mucha
lucha se pudo lograr conseguir los
objetivos mantener los sueños vivos
mantener la llama encendida
gracias
[Aplausos]